I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. That's us. Hey there.
We are here. We are here and we're excited because today we're talking about Hot Girl. Hot Girl, season one, episode six, written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Amy Heckerling. I was really excited to meet Amy Heckerling, you know, growing up. Guys, I might be a child of the 70s, no judgment, the oldie sitting here. No, and she directed Fast Times at Ridgemont High and Clueless and Clueless. So I was excited. I remember there was a bit of a buzz.
Yeah, there was a little bit of a buzz. Then she was coming in. Yeah. We were very excited. I didn't know how to make small talk with her and guess what? I failed. All right, Jenna, hit us with a synopsis. All right, synopsis of this episode, Michael allows a woman selling purses to set up in
the conference room for the day and Michael and Dwight compete for her attention. Very simple. Very simple. And yet. So loaded for Pam. Yeah. Oh. This was really a big Pam episode.
It really was. So should we start with some fast facts then? I know you want to. You know. My Fast Fact, number one, this is the first episode written by Mindy Kaling. Yes, Mindy Kaling's so smart, so funny, and she was one of our most prolific writers on the office. She wrote a total of, Jenna, ready?
What? 22 episodes. Wow. I know. That's like she wrote an entire season of the office. I know. Of our night. Because the season's usually about 22, 24 episodes.
Yes. I have a fan question about Mindy. All right. This is from Bear. Hi, Bear. Yes. Bear asked, this episode was written by Mindy Kaling. What was it like to work with her as a writer versus an actor?
Oh, Bear. Good question. I know. You know what? I loved when Mindy was the writer of the episode. Because the writer of the episode on our show would stay on set all week and produce their episode with the director. So they kind of worked very side by side with the director.
Yes. And they were sort of the liaison back to the writer's room. I loved that our show did this. Not all shows do that. And I really think you benefit from having the writer of the episode on the set with you. Well, Mindy, it was so easy to make Mindy laugh. Like she was so ready to love everything you were doing.
You were filled with such confidence when Mindy was on the set. And she also was really good on the spot coming up with new jokes, because that was another thing that the writer of the episode would do. They would pitch you improvisations on the spot. Yeah. And Mindy, for me, as someone with an improv background, I loved being able to pitch to Mindy because she's so smart. So I could say, hey, Mindy, could I try this?
And then she would just instantly be like, oh, that'd be great. Or how about you do this? And she was such a wonderful creative collaborator. I always felt like Mindy was such a big advocate for the character of Pam as well. I think she was in the writer's room pitching storylines for Pam. And this was a very Pam-centered episode, as we said. Pam has feelings. Just a lot of feelings.
Pam has a lot of feelings. She does. This leads me into my second fastback. I was texting with Mindy about this episode in preparation, and she told me something. The original title of this episode was Purse Girl. Oh. Do you kind of remember that? I actually do because I feel like I have referred to this as Purse Girl a few times
because it's in my brain. Yeah. She also told me that her original draft of this was 39 pages. Wow. Which is a lot, because usually the number of pages that a script is, that's how many minutes of screen time it is. So her script, if we did it exactly as written, would have been 39 minutes, which we would not have been able to air.
I really wish we could have done that, and I wish we could have filmed all 40 pages of that instead of 22, 22 minutes. I remember they used to have those very long table drafts, and then they would cut a bunch of stuff out, and they would make something they called the candy bag. And those were all of the cut scenes, or they were additional takes on scenes. So whatever talking head wound up in the script, there would be five different takes on that talking head in the candy bag. And so we would sit down to do our talking heads, and they would say, all right, well,
we're going to do the scripted one, but then we're going to do three of them from the candy bag. Oh, I remember going to do a talking head, and they handed me three pages of alts, like right in the minute. I'm like, oh, right. Okay, I'm going to have to have a photographic memory. You have to really be on your toes. I think that's something that- It kept us on our toes for sure.
I loved it. I loved it too. And then they used to let me play around and like sort of like put my spin on it too, which was always fun. All right. Fisher, what else you got? All right. I think it's time to talk about Amy Adams.
Okay. I have a lot of note cards here in front of me. I see. And a lot of them have the words Amy or Amy Adams on them. Okay. You tell me when you're ready, because I've got a note card ready to go. Well, this is our third fast fact. Okay.
Amy Adams was the purse girl. Mindy told me that Amy was her favorite from the very beginning. This is who she wanted to cast as the purse girl from her audition. But something that I think people don't realize is that Amy Adams wasn't Amy Adams when she was cast as the purse girl. She became Amy Adams later. And that's an interesting story actually, because we filmed this episode in the fall of 2004, but they didn't start airing until the spring of 2005.
And that fall, she was nominated for an Academy Award for her role in Junebug. Right. When she did this episode of The Office, no one had seen Junebug yet, because Junebug came out in August of 2005. And I remember her first day on set, we were talking and I was like, how are things going? She's like, well, you know, it's good. I mean, I was on a show on CBS called Dr. Vegas, but they like, they let me go. Oh, that's right.
She was like, I kind of got fired. And I was like, no. And she was like, yeah. And I was really down and I was bummed out. But then, you know, I did this little indie movie called Junebug and I, I feel so good about it. And it's going to come out later in the year. And I was like, oh, that sounds great.
Yeah. Let me build you up, Amy Adams. You're going to be just fine. And she was. And she was. But Amy is one of the nicest people. She's so, so sweet. Oh, I loved Amy.
It was so fun working with her. There were a lot of questions from fans asking if we planned to bring this character back after we shot it. Well, we didn't think we were going to have a show, right? There were no real plans to bring her back. But then when the show got picked up, they wanted to bring her back. But now she was Academy Award nominated Amy Adams. I was like, well, I hope we can get her back.
And we did. She came back for two more episodes. Yes. And she was such a great foil, too, for Pam and Jim and all of that. I loved watching that play out. Not only was Amy Adams super nice on set and just like such a pleasure to work with, but I don't know, probably like two years later, I ran into her. I had a friend visiting from Alabama.
And you guys, I don't ever go out. So my friend was coming in town and I was like, oh, I'm going to take her somewhere fancy. That hotel, Chateau Marmont, that's fancy. We'll go there. Because I just had it in my head. Yeah. Like the Hollywood fancy place. It was a fancy place.
It was half an hour from my house. It was such a like hall. But I was like, no, I'll take my friend from Alabama there. So we went and we were having dinner and Amy Adams was at a table and she sent over two glasses of champagne to my friend and I, and I was like, turn, they were like, oh, this is a fancy move. So classy. And they were like, I was like, who's this from?
They were like, it's from Amy Adams. And she waved and then she came over and we chatted, Amy Adams is just a class act. I have a funny Amy Adams story about how people think that we look alike. So she and I were both at this work party thing. I can't remember exactly. I think it was like honoring directors in the industry and we were both there and my friend came up to me and he said, I am so humiliated right now. And I said, what happened?
And he goes, I just went up and bear hugged Amy Adams and said, Jenna, you look beautiful because he mixed us up. And this people have this thing where they think she and I look a lot alike. We really don't look anything alike in person. So I guess I just told a story about someone who mixed us up in person. I mean, there is a resemblance. She's perfectly cast because there is a resemblance and you're both like beautiful ladies. Thanks.
But I see a resemblance. I feel like we could play sisters. You could. All right, Hollywood. You heard it here first. That's how I, that's, I guess that's how I talk when I'm talking to Hollywood. I guess. Hello.
Hollywood beware. Hollywood. This is Angela Kinsey. I don't love it. I would rethink your character, your Hollywood voice lady. I think you should work on it. Okay. Give it an accent.
Should it be British? I only would. No. Oh my God. Oh, that's Australian. Oh, what was that? That was like drunk Scottish. What is happening?
I can't do accents and I also can't sing. I can do Australian, but I grew up overseas and all my best friends were Aussies. So right now I'm just sitting here talking to Jenna. We're going to talk about hot girl. Yeah. That's really good, Ange. Aw, thanks. Thanks so much.
I'm shocked. I'm genuinely impressed. Okay, okay, okay. See, that was so good, but your Hollywood voice is a no. I know. You know what? It's whenever I'm trying to be slick. I am just not programmed to be slick.
This is true about you. I know. Before we go to a break, since we're talking about Amy Adams and how wonderful she is, both on and off set, we have to tell the story about how she helped us meet Meryl Streep. Oh my God. Oh my God. I cannot believe I didn't put that on a note card. I can't believe it either.
What is wrong with me? You know what? I don't know. I got here. There were donuts. I got excited. I forgot. Okay.
So one year, we got to go to the Golden Globes. Oh. The office had been nominated and I have to say, first of all, Angela, I am so grateful that I got to go to these awards show things with you. I know. Well, here's the thing. We didn't go to fancy parties, you guys. We're not fancy people.
I'm an intimate dinner party person. Well, I- I like a small group. I think the fanciest parties I'd ever been to were just like one of my friends would have a big wedding. But I am so glad that I got to navigate all that stuff with you because I would normally kind of freeze up at something like that. But I was there with my BFF.
We would have a couple glasses of wine. We would sometimes get a little. Well, because one thing we should say is we were not allowed to bring a plus one. Well, we were not big time enough. No. I feel like we were barely invited. To truth be told. Even though our show was nominated, it did feel like that.
Well, first of all- Wait, wait, wait. What? Do you remember where our table was? Very far away from the stage. Our table was behind a pillar, Jenna. I had to- I can't remember that.
I had to sort of lean all the way like towards Brian's lap to see the stage. Yeah. So the Golden Globes are really cool because they have awards for both movies and television. There aren't cool movie stars you see. As TV people, we were in the room with Angelina Jolie suddenly and Brad Pitt and all those people. We were nowhere near them, though. They were down at the front and we were in the nosebleeds, but hey, we were in the room.
Well, I will say, I remember going to the bathroom and Angelina Jolie passed by. She took my breath away. I thought, well, now she is from the gods. I get that. I mean, that is a movie star. Well, you turned to me because we were like in line for the bathroom and she just sort of- It's like she glided.
Floated. It's like she floated past us and you turned to me and you go, now that's a movie star. I did. I saw like an old lady. Now that is a movie star. I was like, I don't disagree, Jenna. So Jenna and I are not two people that are invited to a lot of fancy parties. And also, if there are going to be two dorks at a party, chances are they're us.
Oh, yeah. That's just us anywhere. We've done some real dorky things at parties. There are just kind of dorks, even if it's just like at our neighbor's barbecue. I was glad I got to go to those parties with you because I knew you felt as awkward at them as I did, but you are way braver than I am. Way braver. That is true.
I have a little bit of my mom's voice in my ear and my mom would say, if you are at a fancy party, you need to meet the fancy people. You need to use it as an opportunity. Come on. Go say hi to the people you want to say hi to. So I always had that in the back of my head. This is my only chance to meet whoever I've always wanted to meet, I guess. But how do you get into the conversation is always the mystery.
At this Golden Globe, we look across the room and we see Amy Adams talking to Meryl Street. We lean around the pillar, we're sitting behind, and we see Amy Adams. You should know at this point, we've been sitting at our table for quite a while. We hadn't got up and mingled other than we went to the bathroom and saw Angelina Jolie walk by and we didn't say a word. No, I did not speak to her. We did not speak to her. So Jenna's like, there's Amy Adams, and Angela, she's talking to Meryl Street.
We know Amy Adams. Yes. We can go talk to Amy Adams. We know her. She likes us. Yes, and then maybe we'll get to meet some movie stars. Yeah, we'll just basically glom on to Amy Adams was our plan. Yeah.
And Jenna was like, come on, Angela, let's go. And I was like, nope. Don't want to go. Not going. Not going. And you really, like, you were like, Angela. I told you from the table, I said, we are meeting Meryl Street. We are doing this.
This is a story for my mother. Come on. And then she said, and you got to be quick. You have to be quick because what if Amy stops talking to her? Yeah, let's go. And you said, well, what are we going to do? What are we going to say? How do you walk up to them?
What are we going to say? So I was like, here's my plan. We are just going to walk up to them laughing. What? Just laugh. What? And I said, laugh at what? It doesn't matter.
I said, it doesn't matter. Just walk up to them laughing. I think you thought if we just walked up laughing, we would look cool? Like, we're like, I don't know what I thought, Angela. I don't know. I just knew we had to seize the moment. So we did. Well, I said, I basically was like, in shock, I was like, wait, what, what, what?
And then I looked and Jenna was like four strides away, like kind of like, I committed. You're like, come on. And then I sort of half-assed committed behind you. And we did just that. We walked up to Meryl Streep and Amy Adams laughing. And right at that moment, a house photographer came by and snapped our photo. So we have a photo of us and it looks like we are having a hilarious conversation with Meryl Streep and Amy Adams.
Well, actually to clarify, it looks like you and Amy and Meryl Streep are having a great conversation. But because I lagged behind you a little, I was late getting there. And I just look like I'm walking alone laughing. I'm like a good three paces behind you laughing to no one. And you're laughing with Meryl and Amy. But when then the lights like flickered because it was the commercial and we didn't even get to talk to them.
I did get to say to Meryl Streep, I did get to say, it's such a pleasure to meet you. I am a big admirer of your work. And I was, I mean, I just loved her performance in Kramer versus Kramer. I studied a lot of her work. And so as like a theater geek, actor-y person, we've talked a lot about my love of actor prep. That was a big moment for me. Well, I'm glad you had that moment.
I did not meet her. Wait, you didn't meet her? No, no, I didn't meet her because they were dimming the lights. And so the like, by the time I got there, I was just like, bye. Well, she's one of my best friends now. Oh, you. From that moment. You were.
I've never spoken to her again. You've never spoken to her again. I guess that Meryl Streep doesn't quite remember that moment the way we do. I know. Well, we have a photo of it. We do have a photo. All right, guys, we're going to go to a break. And when we come back, we're going to break down the Hot Girl episode.
All right, this episode starts with Michael on a phone call with Jan. She's explaining that they're going to introduce a new incentive program and the top seller in the office is going to get a prize worth $1,000 and that Michael can choose what that prize is the end. So I love that this episode starts with the line, are you listening to me, Michael? By Jan, because he's just like futzing around with pencils and he has her on speakerphone. But I love that the first scene, you just think he's being an idiot. And then you hear this voice say, are you listening to me, Michael?
And I just, I just love it. I love it. The next scene when Dwight is standing over Michael's shoulder in the talking head, begins as a talking head and then it reveals that Dwight is kind of like hovering. That's the first time we did that, but then we will do that many times in the show. It's one of my favorite things is how Dwight stands over Michael's shoulder. That's also when Pam comes into the office to say someone wants to sell handbags and Michael is totally against it, of course, until he sees how attractive the woman is.
A lot of people wrote in and wanted to know where did these purses come from that she's selling. That's Phil Shea. Our prop master. Yes. He told me that he bought them all in downtown LA. Oh, at like the markets downtown? Yes.
Oh, the knockoff purse market? Yes. Because some of them looked really nice, but also they looked a little like pleather. I don't think anyone kept them. I didn't keep one, did you? I didn't know we could. I probably would have taken one. It was early on when we weren't brave enough to ask to take things yet.
Yeah, no. Later, when the show wrapped, I did take Pam's everyday purse. It's just something that had been sitting, even if I didn't use it in a scene, it sat on Pam's desk or it was in her drawer. So I have that. I have Pam's everyday purse that she had for most of the season, but I didn't keep a fancy purse. There's the scene where Michael has to refer to Katie the Purse girl as Pam 6.0.
This was not an improvisation. I have the script from Hot Girl. I have all the scripts from season one. I saved them speaking of saving things and I looked it up. She is like the improved version of me. Like she is. She is not. Yes, she is.
She is not. She is. As your best friend, I am not going to let that slide. She is not. But in this episode, they had really juiced her up. She had a push-up bra on and her hair on. It doesn't matter. Even on our plainest day, Amy Adams is Jenna 6.0.
She is. No, she's not. It's okay with me. No, I'm not. No. Well, okay. Well, whatever. No, I think it's a funny story.
But as your best friend, I'm not going to let you say Amy Adams is a better version of you. It's like we look similar, but then her nose is a little dainty-er and her cheeks are a little rosier and her hair is just a little brighter red. You know what I'm saying? It's just like she just turned it up a couple of notches on the dial and you get Amy Adams. Like if you're creating me, right, you get to me and then if you turn the dial a couple more notches, it turns into Amy Adams.
She's Disney you. She kind of is, she's the Disney princess version of me. Yes. Angela, do you have a note card? Because you're like handling a note card right now. I feel like you want to say a note card. I mean, I have one. It's in your hand and then you're touching them.
What is it that you want to say? Are you annoyed that I'm touching my note card? No, I'm giving you a chance to speak. Oh. Oh, thank you so much. Oh, that was, oh, so it's British when you were offended. Oh, God. No, stop.
Stop. I just want to say that Michael Scott has a talking head that I love so much. And these are just one of these talking heads that they're in every episode and getting to rewatch them. I'm like, ah, my God, that's brilliant. Is it the small businessman? I love it. Is it the things that he reads?
I love that he said he loves American Way Magazine, the in-flight magazine. And then he goes, they did a great profile on Doris Roberts and where she likes to eat when she's in Phoenix. It just made me laugh so hard because I read those. I just want you to know American Airlines whenever I'm flying with you. I get the American way out and I look to see where people eat. It made me laugh so hard. And then he's like illuminating.
I love those magazines too. I read them. And you know, actually one of the coolest things that ever happened to me is that one time I had an article in an in-flight magazine. Yes, just like the Doris Roberts thing, I got profiled. What? I would be so excited. Why didn't you tell me?
That is so cool. No, I told this story about playing poker in Scotland. Oh, wait, wait. I know this is a total tangent. Guys, I'm sorry. I have to take Jen on a tangent because I love this story. Yeah, should I tell this story? You have to tell it.
Okay. Because first of all, it makes you sound way cooler than you are. No offense. I know. But it kind of makes you sound like a rock star. It's my biggest rock star moment of my life. It's 100%. Okay.
So I had no, I know you're going to tell that story, but I need to see that in-flight magazine article. I'll show it to you. It was for United Magazine. And they had this story where they wanted people to tell the craziest ways they've ever fought jet lag. Okay. So Lee and I had this little romantic trip that we took to Scotland.
This was before we had children. I remember this because you told me you were going and I was like, well, that's not a lot of days. Yeah, we only had five days because we had a one week hiatus from work. This is what people without children can do. Yeah, we can just jet off to Scotland for five days. So we were going to spend two days in Edinburgh and then we were going to go into the countryside for the other three days, do a tour of a, you know, like a Scotch factory and everything
really fun. So we get there and we thought we will take an overnight flight. We will sleep on the plane and we will arrive at noon rested and ready to tour Edinburgh. Yeah, right. This did not happen. We did not sleep on the plane and we landed. It was noon and we were thinking how in the world are we going to make it through this whole day?
We were exhausted. So tired. We're touring a castle. We're walking along little shops. We bought some hats and a little hat shop. Oh, wait. I know. I know I'm raising my hand because Jenna, you texted me and I remember you saying, we're
so tired. We're going to try to power through. We're going to try to power through so we don't fall asleep. Yes. You can't fall asleep in the middle of the day. No, then the whole five days you're just going to be sleeping during the day and up at night. So it's five o'clock and we are so exhausted, just so incredibly exhausted.
We thought, here's what we're going to do. We're going to go into a little pub. We're going to get a bite to eat. We're going to have a drink. We are going to force ourselves to stay awake until 7 p.m. and then we're going to go back to the hotel and fall asleep. Right. That was your plan.
Go to the pub, stay power through and then go to bed. Correct. Go to the pub, we order our drink and we see a sign that says poker tournament starting at 6 p.m. All right. I have to interject here. So my BFF, Jenna Fisher, is a flippin' fantastic poker player. I don't know if I'm fantastic, but I love playing.
You are fantastic. Okay. No, you're fantastic. And I once went with her to the Celebrity Poker Showdown story for later, but she's really good at poker. I came in second place. You came in. I mean, that's behind Keegan-Michael Key.
He won. That's a big flex because you beat Michael Ian Black, who still tells me that you beat him in poker. And I mean, you guys, I also just want to say all of this is before I had children. Yeah. I barely play poker anymore. I can't stay awake for anything. I know, but you are really good.
Back in your day, lady. Back in the day. Back in your day before kids. In my youth. In your youth. You were quite the poker player. I think I can win poker with like two pairs of threes and I have all the bravado. Two pairs of threes.
That would be four of a kind. You can. You can win poker with that, Angela. Okay. So, see, this is the problem, but I have no idea what I'm doing. And I think sometimes I mess up a table just because I have such confidence and I have nothing. And then people are like, okay, sometimes that's the best strategy.
Okay, go. You're in Scotland. We're in Scotland. You're trying to stay awake. So tired. We sign up for the poker tournament. Lee, my husband, he plays poker as well. We're thinking, here's what we'll do.
We'll join the poker tournament at 6 p.m. We'll be done at 7. This is how we're going to stay awake that extra hour. You're going to play an hour of poker and then you're going to go to bed. Go to bed. We enter the tournament. We start playing. We start winning.
You're like the two Americans who came in and now you're kicking butt in this pub in Scotland. So much so that we make it to the final table. What time is this? How long have you been there now? It is now midnight. Oh, Jenna. We are out of our minds.
Exhausted. I don't even know what I'm doing. It's probably why I was doing so well. Because you're so loopy. You're playing the best poker of your life. Lee and I are both at the final table and we keep checking in with each other saying, like, should we quit? A couple of times, Lee went all in because he was like, I'm so tired, just all in and
he would win. Finally, I get down to the final two. It's 2 a.m. And it's you and one other person? One local Scottish guy who played every week in the tournament and here you are, this American tired person on her vacation. And I won. You won the whole thing.
I won. I won the whole thing. I won 200 pounds. Wow. Amazing. Lee and I couldn't believe it. Everyone in the pub was a little bit like, yay, yay for her. Did you get your name like up on the wall or something?
Yes. I got my name up on the leaderboard and I was supposed to come back for the championship like table that was happening in several months. Of course, we all knew I wasn't going to show up. So I think the runner up guy got to take my place and then we went back to the hotel and we slept so well and I suffered no jet lag for the rest of that trip. So this was the story. This was the story in the United magazine and I was so proud to be in that magazine.
I'm with Michael Scott. That would have been a heck of a read. I got copies. I sent them to my mom. I sent them to my in-laws. I have one at home. I want you guys to know I woke up back here in the US of A and I had a text from my best friend in Scotland and there was a photo of her in a pub.
Wearing my hat that I had bought by the way. Wearing your hat. My wool hat. And like smiling. And I was like, what is going on? And you were like, I want a poker tournament. I was like, you're supposed to be sleeping. Yeah.
But that's, I mean, truly that is like maybe one of my proudest moments. Yeah. That's a pretty rock star moment, lady. Thank you. I should probably get back to the episode. This is the cringiest episode of the office so far. Not ever. I mean, Scott's tots, but it's cringy.
But diversity day is pretty cringy too. But the whole scene where Michael is talking to Katie about coffee, I was dying. Oh, I was dying. I was also got so weirded out when he was like, you know, all I'm trying to do here is just break down walls. I just tried to break down walls. I was like, what is he talking about? Oh my goodness.
Katie plays it so well. Oh my gosh. She does. And then that scene with Brian over my shoulder asking me if I'm jealous. I laughed so hard during that scene. What was difficult was that I was supposed to sit there and be doing my work and he is hovering over me and then insulting me and I could not get through it. Every time he would start his sentence, it would make me laugh.
That was a scene that I probably laughed the most in when I was shooting this episode. And this leads me into a fan question from Delaney. Did you guys ever get offended by the scripts personally? Like in this episode, how Pam is compared to Katie the whole time, Jenna, did you take that personally? I didn't. Well, I didn't either because I felt like a lot of our comedy was, it was a little bit of a free for all.
Like everyone was going to have a moment, you know, where they were sort of the butt of the joke. But it was never malicious. It was just, it served the script. It served the story. I never took offense. Also, I feel like so much of comedy and comedians is self deprecating in nature. And so we're a group of people who are pretty honest with ourselves, don't you think?
It wasn't offensive to me. It was also, it was the idea that has happened to all of us where a more attractive person walks in the room and is getting all the attention and then you feel, you feel jealous. But I enjoyed this episode. I loved playing with all those feelings. I was going to say. I had a lot of human moments for Pam, just seeing how Jim was affected and how that affected her.
And it was fantastic. I thought you did an excellent job. I have on one of my note cards. Where is it? Jenna? What does it say? Jenna was brilliant. She was.
Thank you, Angela. You were so good. Oh, I don't want to like get us off your, I know you have your list, lady. But the moment when she's like, what are you going to do? And he's like, well, I think actually I'm going to see Katie. The look on your face is Pam. What you did with your eyes in that moment was so amazing. It was interesting.
It was so amazing. You know what I gave myself as a direction in that moment in my head? What? Was when he tells you that, do not blink your eyes. Just stare at him. You're not affected by that. And smile. Because that is great.
Oh, that's great. That was her way of trying to not show how she was feeling, but then show it shows everything. Yeah. It showed everything. It was so great. And that was with Katie, Michael and Toby. Oh, brutal. Oh, Jenna, I watched the deleted scenes this time.
You did? Yes. So I still haven't gotten a DVD player. How'd you do it? I found him online. Okay. I don't know if it was a legal site that I went to, but I went, I clicked on so many things that took me there.
真的吗？是的。所以我还是没买DVD播放器。你是怎么做到的？我在网上找到他的。好吧。我不知道我去的那个是不是合法的网站，但我去了，我点击了好多把我带到那里的链接。
So I don't know. I probably have some inappropriate things on my computer now. Oh boy. No, I'm just saying I clicked, I clicked away. But anyway, I watched the deleted scenes and there is a longer version of that scene where Steve, I know, is just riffing on that whole idea of sad, sack, Toby. And it just, it is so cringy. Oh, I want to go back and watch that.
所以我不知道。我现在电脑里可能有一些不合适的东西。天哪。不，我只是说我点过，我到处乱点。但不管怎样，我看了被删减的片段，那场戏有一个更长的版本，我知道，史蒂夫就在那里即兴发挥，一直在拿那个悲催的托比开涮。那真的太尴尬了。哦，我想回去看那个。
It's really good. So what you see in the episode is just like three seconds of that moment where he's like, oh yeah, you're divorced, right? Sleeping in your car. I loved the, you slept one night in your car, right? Yeah. Made me laugh out loud. Yeah.
真的很棒。所以在剧集里看到的只是那个时刻的大约三秒钟，他就说，哦对了，你离婚了对吧？睡在你的车里。我喜欢那个，你在车里睡了一晚对吧？是的。逗得我哈哈大笑。是的。
It was a long time. Yeah. And Paul's reaction is so perfect. In the deleted scenes, Michael like goes off on him for like minutes. What's so amazing is that Steve and Paul in real life are both of our kind of very gentle, quiet, kind people on the set. And they have to, well, I guess just Michael has to bully Toby, but Steve and Paul's real life relationship is so opposite that.
那是很长一段时间。是的。而且保罗的反应太完美了。在被删减的片段中，迈克尔数落了他整整好几分钟。最神奇的是，史蒂夫和保罗在现实生活中都是我们在片场见过的非常温和、安静、善良的人。而且他们必须，嗯，我猜只是迈克尔必须霸凌托比，但史蒂夫和保罗现实生活中的关系完全相反。
Yeah. So it was, oh, and Katie's like, where am I? Oh, I have some Kinsey Tindall. All right. Let's hear them. At eight minutes, 14 seconds, you, Pam, gets up in a huff from Roy and leaves her salad on the table. Yeah.
是啊。所以，哦，凯蒂就像是在问，我在哪儿？哦，我有金西·廷德尔。好吧。让我们听听他们的。在8分14秒时，你，帕姆，气冲冲地从罗伊身边站起来，把沙拉留在了桌上。是的。
You left your, you didn't pack up your Tupperware or anything and you had a juice box. What are you? I was just been, I had just been insulted. He insulted me. He just, he just said, we're dating. And I had to say, we're not dating. We're engaged. We're very hurt.
你把你的，你没有收拾你的特百惠餐盒什么的，而且你还有一个果汁盒。你是什么人？我只是刚刚，我刚刚被侮辱了。他侮辱了我。他刚刚，他刚刚说，我们在约会。而我不得不说，我们没有在约会。我们订婚了。我们非常受伤。
And I walk away. What do you want? And here's my salad and my Tupperware. Deal with it. Have you never been at a meal and been offended and just left your plate? No. So if you're in a fight with someone over dinner, you, you get up with your plate and you go rinse it off and put it in the dishwasher.
然后我走开。你想怎样？这就是我的沙拉和我的特百惠。随你怎么想。你从来没有在吃饭时被冒犯然后直接扔下盘子走人的经历吗？没有。所以如果你在晚饭时和某人吵架，你，你会端着盘子站起来，去冲洗一下然后放进洗碗机吗？
That's right. I'm going to bust my plate. I'm not going to leave my salad. Well, I would love to see that. Oh, well. I think it would have been so weird if she had taken her food with her. What an odd choice. I thought it was, I think it would be funny if she was mad as hell and had to pack up
没错。我会把盘子砸了。我才不会留下我的沙拉。好吧，我很想看看那个。哦，好吧。如果她把食物也带走了，我觉得会超级奇怪。多么奇怪的选择。我觉得那是，如果她气得要死还得打包
her salad. I have a thing that I wanted to share about Pam's engagement ring to Roy. The props people, when you have to be married on a show, they'll bring you a whole tray of rings. To pick. Yes. You get to pick your engagement ring and your wedding ring. Now these are based on selections that have been pre-edited by the director and producers,
她的沙拉，那才叫搞笑呢。我有一件事想分享，关于帕姆和罗伊的订婚戒指。道具组的人，当你在剧中必须结婚时，他们会拿来一整盘戒指。让你挑。是的。你可以挑选你的订婚戒指和结婚戒指。这些都是根据导演和制片人事先筛选好的选项，
right? So you can't just pick like a honkin' ring. Right. It has to match your character's life. Yes. You have a variety of things to choose from and you have to try them on in different sizes. So when they gave me the tray of rings, I picked a diamond cluster ring as opposed to a diamond solitaire.
对吧？所以你不能随便挑一个大得夸张的戒指。对的。它必须符合你角色的生活。是的。你有很多种选择，而且你必须试戴不同的尺寸。所以当他们把一盘戒指交给我时，我选了一枚群镶钻石戒指，而不是单颗钻石戒指。
And I had it in my mind that Pam has always been hurt, that Roy didn't get her more of the ring she wanted, which would be more of a diamond solitaire, more of what Jim is going to give her later. Right. She's a polite person and she thinks this is, it's not right to be offended by the ring or to not like the ring. So she had to very graciously accept this ring, but I always felt like her opinion of Roy was that he didn't put enough effort into getting to know her or what she would like
而且我心里一直觉得，帕姆总是很受伤，因为罗伊没有给她买她更想要的那种戒指，那会是一枚单钻戒指，更像是吉姆以后要给她的那种。没错。她是个有礼貌的人，她觉得这，对戒指感到被冒犯或者不喜欢这枚戒指是不对的。所以她不得不非常亲切地接受这枚戒指，但我总觉得她对罗伊的看法是，他在了解她或了解她喜欢什么方面没有付出足够的努力
or he didn't put a lot of effort into the engagement ring or the relationship or the relationship, but that the ring is really a symbol of his lack of effort and his lack of knowing her and every day when I would look down at that diamond cluster ring, it would just poke at those wounds that she has in her relationship with Roy. And so when he says boyfriend, that's another way that she's like, that's right. This ring makes me feel like we're not engaged. I've been wearing this diamond cluster ring for three years and it feels like a thing that you give your girlfriend.
或者他在订婚戒指或关系上没有付出很多努力，或者说这段关系，但那枚戒指确实是他缺乏努力和不够了解她的象征，每当我低头看着那枚群镶钻石戒指时，它就会刺痛她在与罗伊的关系中所受到的那些创伤。所以当他说男朋友时，这是她心里想的另一种方式，没错。这枚戒指让我觉得我们没有订婚。我戴这枚群镶钻石戒指已经三年了，它感觉就像是你送给女朋友的东西。
It doesn't feel like what you give someone when you're proposing. At least for Pam, does that make sense? It does. And it also just makes me sad. And now I take back my salad. My salad judgment. So you see how hurt she was. She was very hurt.
它感觉不像是求婚时送的东西。至少对帕姆来说是这样，这说得通吗？说得通。这也让我感到难过。现在我收回我对沙拉的看法。我对沙拉的评判。所以你看出她有多受伤了。她非常受伤。
You see the history there. Yes. She can't clean up a salad in that moment, Angela. No. Yeah. No. In that moment, she's like three years, three years I've sat here and you haven't noticed me.
你能看到那段历史。是的。在那一刻，她根本没法去清理一盘沙拉，安吉拉。没有。是的。没有。那一刻，她的内心想法是：三年了，整整三年我坐在这里，而你却没有注意到我。
Yes. That's what's raging inside her. And this is probably one of the biggest displays of hurt and anger that Pam has ever had. Yeah. I'm going to take that out. No. Okay.
是的。这就是在她内心翻江倒海的东西。这可能是帕姆表现出最大程度的受伤和愤怒的时刻之一了。是的。我要把那个收回。不。好吧。
I take back the salad packing up. Thank you. Okay. Thank you very much. But do you want to explain to me why at nine minutes, 23 seconds, ET is back on Jim's desk. Wow. Yeah.
我收回关于打包沙拉的话。谢谢。好吧。非常感谢。但你想向我解释一下，为什么在9分23秒时，E.T.又回到了吉姆的桌子上吗？哇。是的。
ET in his blue robe, back on Jim's desk. So it was on the desk and then off. Oh, Sam's going to bring up ET. They're looking at it, so I make suggestions. Wait for it. Here's the thing. Okay. You just keep talking.
E.T.穿着它的蓝色长袍，又回到了吉姆的桌子上。所以它先是在桌上，然后又不在了。哦，萨姆要把E.T.的事提出来了。他们在看这个，所以我会提出建议。等着瞧。事情是这样的。好吧。你继续说。
See ET? See ET? Dude, I see it. What is that? I don't know! We need to find out from John. Or Phil Shae. We will text John and Phil and get an answer.
看到E.T.了吗？看到E.T.了吗？老兄，我看到了。那是什么？我不知道！我们需要向约翰打听一下。或者菲尔·谢伊。我们会给约翰和菲尔发信息，然后得到一个答案。
Mm-hmm. I have a fan question. Okay. This is from Mary Beth. The scene where Dwight is talking to Katie about buying a purse when Jim and Pam start awkwardly narrating the interaction. Was that scene scripted or did John and Jenna just play off whatever Reign decided to do? It was improvised.
嗯。我有一个粉丝提问。好吧。这是来自玛丽·贝丝的提问。德怀特和凯蒂谈论买钱包的那场戏，当时吉姆和帕姆开始尴尬地对这场互动进行旁白解说。那场戏是剧本里写好的，还是约翰和詹娜只是顺着雷恩决定做的事情即兴发挥的？那是即兴发挥的。
We were on set, and we had a little scripted scene, and then it was suggested that we narrate what was going on. I think it was John's idea. So Rain knew that we were going to do that, so he started doing all kinds of crazy stuff with the purses, like slamming on the desk, and like trying to put it in, yes, exactly, to give us weird things to say. And I really froze. I am not a great improviser in like comedy improv sketch comedy.
我们在片场，我们有一个写好的小剧本，然后有人建议我们对正在发生的事情进行旁白解说。我想那是约翰的主意。所以雷恩知道我们要这么做，于是他开始对那些钱包做出各种疯狂的举动，比如往桌子上摔，还试图把它放进去，是的，完全是这样，好给我们提供一些奇怪的台词可说。而我真的僵住了。我在喜剧即兴表演或小品喜剧方面并不是个出色的即兴表演者。
I took a couple of those classes, and I always really tanked. I froze. I'm very good at improvising in a specific character, but not if the specific character has to be funny and say clever things. That's not my forte. It's okay, lady. You know, you're good at it. You, that was your thing.
我上过好几节这样的课，而且我每次都演砸了。我僵住了。我很擅长在扮演特定角色时进行即兴发挥，但如果这个特定角色必须搞笑并说出聪明的话，那就不行了。那不是我的强项。没关系，女士。你知道的，你很擅长。你，那是你的拿手好戏。
I love it. I know. I love it. I love the plot at this point in the episode, Michael buys a Starbucks coffee machine. A thousand dollars. A thousand dollars. This is going to be the incentive for the salesperson who sells the most, but then he unwraps it and makes Katie the Purse girl a cup of coffee.
我喜欢。我知道。我喜欢。我喜欢剧集这个阶段的情节，迈克尔买了一台星巴克咖啡机。一千美元。一千美元。这将是对销售业绩最好的销售人员的奖励，但他却把它拆开包装，给卖包女孩凯蒂倒了一杯咖啡。
He's so creepy that he's used this coffee thing to flirt with her. He's so creepy with it. I love his line, though, where he says, Dunder Mifflin in the 80s, before they knew how bad cocaine was. Man, did they move paper. Man, did they move paper. I love that line. I also remember the scene with Michael and Dwight.
他太令人毛骨悚然了，竟然用这台咖啡机来调戏她。他这样做真的太让人毛骨悚然了。不过我喜欢他的那句台词，他说，80年代的邓德·米夫林，在他们还不知道可卡因有多坏之前。天哪，他们卖出的纸可真多。天哪，他们卖出的纸可真多。我喜欢那句台词。我还记得迈克尔和德怀特的对手戏。
Michael tells Dwight that he's going to be giving Katie a ride home and Dwight asking if he loves her. Do you love her? Do you love her? I remember they could not get through that scene. The two of them were cracking each other up. It went on forever. Not only do I love that Dwight is like, do you love her?
迈克尔告诉德怀特他要送凯蒂回家，而德怀特问他是否爱她。你爱她吗？你爱她吗？我记得他们怎么都过不了那场戏。他们俩把对方逗得哈哈大笑。这持续了太久。我不但喜欢德怀特说“你爱她吗？”
I love that Michael is like, I don't know. Maybe. I can't say. I can't say. I don't know yet. The two of them are ridiculous. And then you have Roy, who decides he's going to try to make up with Pam, and he decides to start tickling you while you're sitting on Jim's desk.
我还喜欢迈克尔说，“我不知道。也许吧。我不能说。我不能说。我还不知道。”他们两个太荒谬了。然后你看到罗伊，他决定要和帕姆重修旧好，他决定当你坐在吉姆的桌子上时开始给你挠痒痒。
So awkward. Next to Jim. I remember filming that scene. When I watched it, I felt so uncomfortable for Jim. I was like, oh, God, Jim. And then he gets up and he walks away. Yes. Yes.
太尴尬了。就在吉姆旁边。我记得拍摄那场戏的情景。当我看到它时，我替吉姆感到无比尴尬。我在想，哦，天哪，吉姆。然后他站起来走开了。是的。是的。
So here's something interesting about that. I, as Jenna, hate being tickled. Yeah, you hate it. I don't like it. It is not. I would not be the way to make up with me. You'd make you angry. I would.
所以关于这个有个有趣的事。我，作为詹娜，讨厌别人给我挠痒痒。是的，你讨厌。我不喜欢。这不是。这绝对不是和我重修旧好的方式。会惹恼你的。我会的。
Yeah. I would be like, no. And I think that when I was filming that, I had to really wrap my head around the fact this is a way that Jenna and Pam are different. Yeah. Pam is won over by it. Pam is like, oh, come on. Oh, no.
是的。我会说，不要。而且我觉得当我拍那场戏时，我必须在脑海里反复消化这个事实：这就是詹娜和帕姆的不同之处。是的。帕姆被这一招拿下了。帕姆就像是，哦，拜托。哦，不。
That is how they make up. Yeah. Pam and Roy are friends again, or I guess engaged after that moment. Whatever they are. They're back. Whatever they are, they're back. And as Jenna, I had to really stuff all of my Jenna instincts because I do not like tickling. Well, and some people really don't like being tickled.
他们就是这样和好的。是的。在那一刻之后，帕姆和罗伊又成了朋友，或者我猜是订婚了。不管他们是什么状态。他们复合了。不管他们是什么状态，他们复合了。而作为詹娜，我不得不极力压抑我所有的詹娜本能，因为我真的很讨厌挠痒痒。嗯，而且有些人真的很讨厌别人给他们挠痒痒。
I don't like being scared. Oh, I know. So like, well, and my husband, like once a year around Halloween. You don't like being startled or scared. I don't like, I don't like scary movies. You don't respond well. I don't go to scary movies. And my dad was the same way.
我讨厌被吓到。哦，我知道。所以，嗯，还有我丈夫，比如一年一次在万圣节前后。你讨厌被惊吓或吓到。我不喜欢，我不喜欢恐怖电影。你的反应不会很好。我不去看恐怖电影。我爸爸也是这样。
So you know how they say some people are like, fight or flight? Yeah. I am fight. And so Josh, my husband, like around Halloween, him and the kids think it's funny to get like a fake arm or a mask and scare me. And I always say to them, one of you will get whacked. You know that. And I have no control.
所以你知道他们怎么说有些人是“战斗还是逃跑”反应吗？是的。我是“战斗”型。所以乔什，我丈夫，在万圣节前后，他和孩子们觉得拿个假胳膊或面具来吓唬我很有趣。我总是对他们说，你们中会有人挨揍的。你们知道的。而且我无法控制。
You flail your arms when people scare you. Yeah. I've seen it happen. I have no control over it. Just recently, my husband for Halloween, they jumped out to scare me, had this mask on. And I screamed. And then with everything I had, I hooked my phone at him.
别人吓你时你会挥舞手臂。是的。我见过这种事发生。我对此毫无控制力。就在最近，我丈夫为了万圣节，他们跳出来吓唬我，戴着这个面具。我尖叫了。然后我用尽全身力气，把手机朝他砸过去。
And I hit him with my phone, clearly, like I didn't mean to. It's just like this weird instinctual thing where I just go, yeah. You need to hope that you never have to do a scene where someone scares you. It'll be very. Because you will. How will you keep your arms from not whacking? I don't know. I don't know.
我用手机砸了他，显然，我不是故意的。这就像是一种奇怪的本能反应，我就会发出，呀。你得祈祷自己永远不用去演那种别人吓你的戏。那会非常。因为你会的。你怎么能控制住自己的手臂不去挥舞呢？我不知道。我不知道。
Someone will get. Someone will get first. That was the difficulty for me in that scene because tickling me makes me irritated. You want to whack someone? Not make me laugh. Well, I thought you did a great job and it was cringy as heck. Yeah. Poor Jim.
总会有人。总会有人先挨打。那对我来说是那场戏的难处，因为挠痒痒让我感到烦躁。你想揍人？而不是逗我笑。嗯，我觉得你表现得很棒，而且尴尬得要命。是的。可怜的吉姆。
I'm going to go to a break. Let's take a break. Angela, I want to start by asking you a question. Okay. You know the scene where Dwight is asking Katie on the date and it's in front of your character because you're looking at Purse's? Your face during that moment, what were you thinking? I did not even look up.
我要去休息一下。我们休息一下吧。安吉拉，我想先问你一个问题。好吧。你知道德怀特邀请凯蒂约会的那场戏吗，就在你角色面前，因为你在看钱包？你当时的表情，你在想什么？我甚至都没有抬头。
No. You just kept your eyes down. I kept my eyes down and then I didn't look up until he walked out of the room and you can see when he exits, I kind of look up and look at him leave. You know, in that moment, it was so awkward and uncomfortable. I wasn't given direction to do that, but I just felt so uncomfortable. I just kept looking down. But Dwangela is not a thing yet.
没有。你只是把目光垂着。我把目光垂着，直到他走出房间我才抬头，你可以看到他离开时，我抬头看了一眼他离开。你知道，在那个时刻，太尴尬、太不舒服了。我没有接到要这么做的导演指示，但我实在觉得太不舒服了。我只好一直看着下面。但“德安吉拉”当时还不存在。
No. But it is so easy to superimpose what we know is going to happen between your two characters onto this moment. But people were asking if you knew that your characters were going to end up together in that moment yet. But you didn't, right? I didn't know. I didn't know.
没有。但是要把我们明知以后会在你俩角色之间发生的事情强加到这个时刻，实在是太容易了。但人们问过，当时你是否知道你们的角色最后会走到一起。但你不知道，对吧？我不知道。我不知道。
And just in that conference room, it's not a huge space. And him putting himself out there like that to her, I as Angela, and like even as myself felt so uncomfortable that I just was trying somehow not to participate in the moment in any way. Like try to just be invisible. Yeah. I was in my mind, I was like, just be invisible. I think that, you know, Angela didn't know that Dwight was going to be her soulmate, but
而且就在那个会议室里，空间并不大。他那样向她袒露心迹，我作为安吉拉，甚至作为我自己，都觉得太不舒服了，以至于我只想设法不以任何方式参与到那一刻中去。就像是试着当个隐形人。是的。我当时心里想的就是，当个隐形人。我觉得，你知道，安吉拉并不知道德怀特会成为她的灵魂伴侣，但是
I think she did see him as an equal and she respected his work ethic and probably respected who he was in the office, even though he annoyed her, right? Sure. There was a power struggle between the two of them. So to see him sort of humble himself like that to Katie and get humiliated, I just felt like I didn't even want him to think that I had witnessed it. I didn't see it. It didn't happen.
我觉得她确实把他视为平等的人，她尊重他的职业道德，可能也尊重他在办公室里的为人，尽管他惹恼了她，对吧？当然。他们两个之间存在着权力斗争。所以看到他那样向凯蒂放低姿态却受到羞辱，我当时甚至觉得我都不想让他以为我目睹了这一切。我没看见。这没有发生。
It's okay. That's, I think, what she was thinking. And that's why I didn't look up. I was literally trying to be invisible in the moment. Well, after that, you have a line that is one of my favorite lines of your character, where you describe your favorite colors. This is a fan question from Emmy. Angela, did you improvise a scene where you discussed your colors being different shades
没关系。我想，这就是她当时的想法。这就是为什么我没有抬头。我当时真的是在努力当个隐形人。好吧，在那之后，你有一句台词，是你角色的台词中最让我喜欢的其中一句，你在那句台词里描述了你最喜欢的颜色。这是一个来自埃米的粉丝提问。安吉拉，你有没有即兴发挥过讨论你喜欢的颜色是不同深浅的灰色的那场戏？
of gray? Yes, I did. I knew it. Yes, I did. In the episode, Dwight is looking in at the conference room at Katie and Angela sort of talking, and we didn't have any scripted dialogue, so they said, can you just kind of banter? And I didn't even know if it would make it in, you know?
是的，我演了。我就知道。是的，我演了。在剧中，德怀特正往会议室里看，看着凯蒂和安吉拉在聊天，我们没有任何剧本台词，所以他们说，你们能随便聊聊天吗？我甚至不知道这会不会被剪进正片里，你知道吗？
And so that scene was improvised, and it starts off with Amy as Katie saying, well, you seem to like to touch things, and then I just responded. I don't like to necessarily touch things. I'm shopping, you know? I loved that line. And then she said, well, what color do you like? And this was all improvised. And I said gray, dark gray, charcoal, and it made it in, and that was really fun.
所以那场戏是即兴发挥的，开场是扮演凯蒂的埃米说，嗯，你好像喜欢摸东西，然后我就回应了。我不一定喜欢摸东西。我在购物，你知道的？我太喜欢那句台词了。然后她说，好吧，你喜欢什么颜色？而这一切都是即兴发挥的。我说灰色、深灰色、炭灰色，而这居然被剪进去了，真的非常有趣。
And then that line ended up in a article in the newspaper. It was talking about what sums up the show, and they said, well, the character Angela's line, gray, dark gray, charcoal, really sets the tone, and I was so proud of that. It really then informed a lot of your wardrobe after that. You had been kind of wearing these muted colors, but that became your uniform moving forward. Okay, Jenna, what else do you have? All right, the scene where Ryan and Michael are cleaning out his car? That was not improvised.
然后那句台词最后还登上了报纸的一篇文章。那篇文章在讨论什么能概括这部剧，他们说，剧中角色安吉拉的台词“灰色、深灰色、炭灰色”真的定下了基调，我为此感到非常骄傲。它确实为之后你的很多戏服提供了参考。你之前一直穿着这些素色，但那成了你以后标志性的统一着装。好吧，詹娜，你还有什么？好的，瑞恩和迈克尔在清理他的车的那个场景？那不是即兴发挥的。
No, that was scripted. A lot of people asked, all of it, blue blast, smell alike, how many filet of fish do you eat? All of those lines are in the script. I checked, because when I was watching it, it was so hard for me to believe that it was not improvised, that I went back to my script and I read it, and I think that it just points to how good the writing was on our show. Fantastic.
不，那是剧本写好的。很多人问过，所有的那些，蓝色冲击波、闻起来一样、你吃了几个菲力鱼堡？所有这些台词都在剧本里。我查过了，因为我在看的时候，很难相信这不是即兴发挥的，所以我翻回剧本读了一遍，我觉得这恰恰说明了我们剧的编剧有多么出色。太棒了。
Just how good. And also, how good the actors were. I mean, BJ and Steve in that scene, just absolutely brilliant. Mindy also told me that the reference to the filet of fishes is a nod to her disgusting love of filet of fish in real life. Or just her love for McDonald's. She loves McDonald's. But that she really does love a filet of fish.
就是这么出色。还有，演员们的演技有多么精湛。我是说，BJ和史蒂夫在那场戏里，简直绝了。敏迪还告诉我，提到菲力鱼堡其实是在向她现实生活中对菲力鱼堡令人发指的喜爱致敬。或者只是她对麦当劳的喜爱。她爱麦当劳。但她确实很喜欢菲力鱼堡。
I loved in the scene too, when Michael's like, that was over a period of time, okay? It was over a month. It was over a month. And Ryan the temp goes, still. Yeah. I could watch that scene over and over again. I think that's a gem. I think if you haven't rewatched this episode, but you're listening to the podcast, just
我也很喜欢那场戏里迈克尔说的那句，那是隔了一段时间的，好吗？那是一个多月的时间。那是一个多月。而临时工瑞恩说，依然很恶心。是的。那场戏我可以看了一遍又一遍。我觉得那是个宝藏片段。我觉得如果你还没重温过这一集，但你在听播客，那么请
please go watch that scene. It's so good. It is terrific. Blue is not a flavor. I have a note card. Say it. Okay. This is a great, great Dwight line when he says, Shroots produce very thirsty babies.
一定要去看看那场戏。太棒了。真的太精彩了。蓝色不是一种味道。我有一张卡片。念出来。好吧。这是一句非常非常棒的德怀特台词，他说，施鲁特家族会产下非常口渴的婴儿。
Oh, yes. That's a famous line. That's a famous line. Um, when I was pregnant, I was pregnant season five of the office and I got a gift of a t-shirt that said Shroots produce very thirsty babies and it was a maternity shirt. Oh my God. And I wore that around my big belly and people would freak out. I still have it.
哦，是的。那是一句名言。那是一句名言。嗯，当我怀孕的时候，我在《办公室》第五季时怀孕了，我收到了一件T恤作为礼物，上面写着“施鲁特家族会产下非常口渴的婴儿”，那是一件孕妇装。哦，天哪。我穿着它挺着个大肚子到处走，人们都会被吓到。我到现在还留着它。
I still have it. Oh, do you have a picture of yourself in that? I will look, but if I don't, I'll just take a picture of myself in it and I'll have to post that on office ladies pod because I still have that shirt. You should definitely. Here is something that everybody wrote in about. This was one of our most popular questions. What's up with the wrong parking lot at the end of this episode?
我到现在还留着它。哦，你有自己穿着那件衣服的照片吗？我会找找看的，如果没有，我就自己穿着它拍张照，然后我得把它发到“办公室女士”播客上去，因为我真的还留着那件衬衫。你绝对应该这么做。这里有个所有人都在留言讨论的问题。这是我们最受欢迎的问题之一。这集结尾时那个错误的停车场是怎么回事？
That's because this was the original set before we moved. The first six episodes, we all filmed at an actual office building in Culver City and that was the parking lot. Yes. So when we moved in season two and beyond, we had two sound stages. One sound stage was a recreation of the office, that interior office that we shot in the first year. The other building is where the writers worked and it was just an office building and that
那是因为这是我们搬迁之前的原始片场。前六集，我们都是在一个真实的办公大楼里拍摄的，就在卡尔弗城，那个就是停车场。是的。所以当我们第二季及以后搬家时，我们有两个摄影棚。一个摄影棚是办公室的复刻，也就是我们在第一年拍摄的那个室内办公室。另一个建筑是编剧们工作的地方，那只是一栋办公楼，而
was just the parking lot for it. Yes. And that is where we filmed the Dunder Mifflin parking lot. So it was really interesting because we had our warehouse set over there and then we had the parking lot and we had the lobby and the elevator where Hank sat. Yes. All of that was one building, but then the Dunder Mifflin building was something else. So if we had to do a scene where you see us walk out, we would have to start that scene
那只是它的停车场。是的。而那就是我们拍摄邓德·米夫林停车场的地方。所以这真的很有趣，因为我们的仓库片场在那边，然后我们有停车场，还有大堂和汉克值班的电梯。是的。所有这些都在同一栋楼里，但邓德·米夫林大楼是另一个地方。所以如果我们必须拍一场看到我们走出来的戏，我们就必须把那场戏开始
in one building and then move all the cameras and all of us over to the other building and then get the exterior version of it. Yes. It was quite complicated. It was. Basically, when we filmed in one stage indoors, we filmed another stage outdoors for the most part, but that parking lot is not the Dunder Mifflin parking lot that you see from season two and beyond.
在其中一栋楼里，然后把所有的摄像机和我们所有人都搬到另一栋楼去，然后拍出它的外观镜头。是的。这相当复杂。确实如此。基本上，当我们在一个摄影棚里拍室内戏时，我们大部分时间会在另一个摄影棚拍室外戏，但那个停车场并不是你在第二季及以后看到的那个邓德·米夫林停车场。
And I have a story about that parking lot. You see in that final shot, it starts with Michael and Jim and Katie leaving. She's got her big bag, Michael realizes that Jim is going to be giving her ride home because they're going to get drinks. And then it reveals Pam and Roy backing up in Roy's truck and Pam clocks Jim and Katie. So David and I had to sit in that truck in the parking lot and wait a very long time until everyone came out and did that scene. And we had a little walkie-talkie inside the truck and they would say, go.
关于那个停车场我还有一个故事。你在最后一个镜头里看到，以迈克尔、吉姆和凯蒂离开开场。她拿着她的大包，迈克尔意识到吉姆要顺便送她回家，因为他们要去喝一杯。然后镜头揭示出帕姆和罗伊在罗伊的卡车里倒车，帕姆注意到了吉姆和凯蒂。所以大卫和我不得不坐在停车场的那辆卡车里，等了很长时间，直到所有人都出来拍了那场戏。我们在卡车里有一个对讲机，他们会说，走。
And then David would back up and we would pull out and the camera would get that shot of me looking sad and we would drive off. And then they would say, reset. And we would bring the truck back and then we would wait a very long time. At the end of the night, they reset us back into the parking lot and we sat there and we sat there in the truck. We sat there in the truck and then all of a sudden we saw everyone driving away in their own cars.
然后大卫倒车，我们把车开出去，镜头拍到我看起来很难过的那个镜头，然后我们开走。然后他们会说，重置。我们把卡车开回来，然后我们等了很久。天黑收工时，他们把我们重置回停车场里，我们就坐在那儿，在卡车里坐着。我们就坐在卡车里，然后突然我们看到每个人都开着自己的车走了。
Oh, no. They left us in the truck. They forgot to tell us that they had wrapped for the day. And we were all done and we were leaving. You were done. You were changing clothes. You were getting in your cars. We saw the director leave.
哦，不。他们把我们留在卡车里了。他们忘了告诉我们今天已经收工了。大家都完工了，准备走了。你们都结束了。你们在换衣服。你们在坐上各自的车。我们看到导演走了。
We saw actors. David and I were like, what is going on? So and here's the thing, I've talked about this before. David Denman and I were very good friends in real life. We talked about in the basketball episode how you and I became best friends because we had to sit on that bench for hours and hours. This is really the episode where David and I became such good friends. Well, you had a lot of like St. Louis connections.
我们看到演员们走了。大卫和我都惊了：这到底是怎么回事？所以，这里有个情况，我以前也说过。大卫·邓门和我现实生活中是非常好的朋友。我们在聊篮球那一集时谈到过你和我怎么成了好朋友，因为我们不得不在那个长椅上坐上整整几个小时。这真的才是大卫和我成为这么要好的朋友的一集。嗯，你们有很多圣路易斯的共同联系。
We did. We had mutual friends. And we had the poker connection. Yes. David and I played in a poker game together with our crew. We would host these poker games. Rain was in on it. Chris Workman, who was one of our camera operators, Ed, our camera assistant.
我们是的。我们有共同的朋友。而且我们有扑克之缘。是的。大卫和我跟我们的剧组一起玩过扑克局。我们会组织这些扑克局。雷恩也参与了。克里斯·沃克曼，我们的摄像师之一，还有埃德，我们的摄像助理。
We would all get together and we would play poker. And he was part of that. So he was one of my poker pals. And anyway, this was the episode where we really became friends because we got left in that truck. You got stuck in that truck. Jenny, do you know what? I'm seeing the theme here that you become really close friends with people that you
我们都会聚在一起玩扑克。他是其中的一员。所以他是我的扑克牌友之一。不管怎样，这一集就是大卫和我真正成为朋友的一集，因为我们被忘在那个卡车里了。你们被困在那个卡车里了。詹娜，你知道吗？我发现了一个规律，你好像总是能和那些与你处在
are in a confined space with. I get stuck with. You're stuck on a bench. I'll be Angela's best friend. I'm stuck in a truck. David, let's play poker. Get stuck in an elevator with me. And then you're going to be best friends.
狭窄空间里的人成为超级好朋友。我被困住的人。你被困在长椅上。我会成为安吉拉的好朋友。我被困在卡车里。大卫，我们来玩扑克吧。跟我一起被困在电梯里吧。然后你就会成为好朋友。
Friends for life. I have my final note card. Ready? Yes. All right. At around 21 minutes, 25 seconds, you see both Meredith, played by Kate Flannery, and Meredith, played by Henriette, in the same episode. Yes, you saw it, Angela.
生死之交。我还有最后一张卡片。准备好了吗？是的。好的。在大约21分25秒时，你可以看到由凯特·弗兰纳里扮演的梅雷迪思和由亨利埃特扮演的梅雷迪思，出现在同一集中。是的，你看到了，安吉拉。
Yes, I saw it and I almost texted you, background expert, but I thought, no, I'm going to wait and see if she sees it. Yes, this is a huge mistake. It's a huge mistake. So basically, while Michael has this talking head, they want to show all these clips of different women in the office, and they used, like, some footage from the pilot before Kate Flannery came on, and it was Henriette as Meredith. You have this montage that goes Kate Flannery to Henriette to Luanne, who played in the
是的，我看到了，我差点给你发信息说“背景专家”，但我心想，不，我要等等看她能不能看到。是的，这是一个巨大的失误。这是一个巨大的失误。基本上，当迈克尔在做单人访谈时，他们想展示办公室里不同女性的各种剪辑片段，他们使用了，比如在凯特·弗兰纳里加入之前试播集的某些素材，里面亨利埃特演的是梅雷迪思。你们看到了这样一个蒙太奇，从凯特·弗兰纳里切换到亨利埃特，再切换到露安，她在
Annex. Who was one of our extras for a very long time, so that makes sense. I saw that, and I got so excited for you. I got so excited. Because you knew. I knew you were going to clock it. She knew I had my note card ready. I have a final little tidbit.
附楼演过角色。她做了我们很久的群演，所以这说得通。我看到了，我为你感到好激动。我超级激动。因为你知道。我知道你会发现的。她知道我已经准备好我的卡片了。我还有一个最后的趣闻。
I have a Fisher tidbit, the coffee maker. We never find out who won the coffee maker. No. I'm feeling like I need to know. We never find out who won it, and we never see it again. We never see it again. So it doesn't stay in the office. I asked Phil Shea, because a fan wrote in, they wanted to know, did any of us get to
我有一个关于费舍尔的趣闻，咖啡机。我们再也没找到是谁赢了这台咖啡机。没有。我觉得我需要知道答案。我们再也没看到是谁赢了，也再没见过它。我们再也没见过它。所以它没有留在办公室里。我问过菲尔·谢伊，因为有个粉丝写信来，他们想知道，我们当中有人把这台机器留下了吗？
keep it? People are very interested in the things we're allowed to keep and not keep. I get it. He said no. He said it was borrowed from Starbucks and had to be returned. I believe that. Where is that machine now? I actually believe that, and I bet the purses were returned, because we were on a tight budget
大家对我们被允许留下和不被允许留下的东西非常感兴趣。我懂的。他说没有。他说那是从星巴克借来的，必须归还。我信。那台机器现在在哪里？我其实相信这一点，我敢打赌那些钱包也退还了，因为我们当时预算紧张
and we thought we were getting canceled, and we didn't want to give NBC any reason to think we were trouble. That's right. So I think I believe that all of that was returned, and we got to recoup that money. For sure. Well, Jenna, I think that was some really fun fast facts. You did a great job. Wow, thank you.
而且我们以为节目要被砍了，我们不想给NBC任何理由觉得我们在添乱。没错。所以我相信所有这些东西都退还了，我们还得把钱收回来。肯定的。好吧，詹娜，我觉得那是一些非常有趣的快讯。你做得太棒了。哇，谢谢。
You're welcome. I really appreciate it, Angela. Oh, no, no, no. I think. Now I need to hear you sing, because if that's what you sound like, I just realize we've never done karaoke or anything together. On the wings of love, only the two of us together fly in high. Okay, don't sing anymore.
不客气。我真的很感激，安吉拉。哦，不，不，不。我觉得。现在我得听你唱歌了，如果那就是你的歌声，我刚意识到我们从来没有一起唱过卡拉OK什么的。在爱的翅膀上，只有我们两个一起高飞。好吧，别再唱了。
We'll have to pay for it. But now I know you're, now I have got your karaoke voice, and it's whispery. Well, it's whispery. It's trying to cover up my flaws, and if you can't really sing, you whisper sing. And that was hot, girl, and that wraps up season one. Season one, where you and I become best friends, because you were stuck on a bench with me, and where you also became friends with someone because you were stuck in a car with them. See a pattern here.
我们可付不起版权费。不过现在我知道了，现在我掌握了你的卡拉OK唱腔，是那种气声。嗯，是气声。这是在试图掩盖我的缺点，如果你真的不会唱歌，你就会用气声唱。太棒了，女孩，第一季就此结束。第一季，你和我成了生死之交，因为你跟我一起被困在长椅上，而且你也和某人成了朋友，因为你跟他们一起被困在车里。看出规律了吧。
What's going to happen season two? Who do I get stuck with in season two? Dun, dun, dun, speaking of season two, we are going to start with the Dundee. Oh, I can't wait. That's a big episode. A very, very big episode. All right. We'll see you next week.
第二季会发生什么？我在第二季里会被困在谁身边？咚、咚、咚，说到第二季，我们将从“邓迪奖”开始。哦，我等不及了。那是一集大制作。非常非常大的一集。好吧。我们下周见。
See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Keeper. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Remember, you can listen to ad-free versions of Office Ladies on Stitcher Premium. For a free month of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下周见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基珀。我们的主题曲是布雷顿·克里德的《橡胶树》。记住，你可以在Stitcher Premium上收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》。免费体验一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码：Office。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。